Tim you've uh you've made I feel like
you've made quite a name for yourself
with your with the short videos that you
do on social media have you gotten
anybody upset over the content as Megan
McCain she doesn't like she doesn't like
you she's like I know someone that knows
her well she's not a fan of me well your
portrayal of her and I like you and I
like her yeah your portrayal of her is
not flattering
no but it's accurate I think that's the
real you gotta know I have yet yeah I
felt Megan would not enjoy but again
she's rich enough and everything where
you got to just kind of relax yes but
then as far as other people that were
angry I think most people I mean we pick
on a lot of dead people
Lou Pearlman can't really although he
wouldn't be happy probably yeah Epstein
Epstein's
gone but he you know we not forgotten
the most recent thing we did was funny
is like we were canvassing for Bernie
Sanders in Beverly Hills we sort of that
was very funny just to walk around like
a neighborhood of billionaires and tell
them you know how much we need to change
and you know we thought we get it thrown
out of the area where like the cops
would be here in five minutes and you
realize that nobody lives in any of
those nobody's ever homes right one
cares so yeah most of the time what we
do is so over the top and ridiculous you
can't get upset about did people answer
the door for you know they're not home
you kids just gates you can't even get
in the door you're just standing outside
the gate really canvassing for Bernie
great idea I just thought it was a funny
thing to do you know Bernie won't do
well there yeah I just kept knocking on
the door being like he's also Jewish
give him a shot right but yeah most
people I think they're so over the top
most people don't care yeah do you know
do you feel like you're gonna do less
Megan McCain now that you know she's not
happy with it or done or twice and I
don't I might do her one more time I
don't know I don't she is super fun
she's a ridiculous figure and when
you're a ridiculous figure you gotta be
made fun of I mean I don't even I don't
hate all right you know I'm sure we
would agree on certain things but what
she's ridiculous her it's ridiculous
that she has that job it's ridiculous
that she's you know is an authority on
on something but it isn't it funny the
way she gets everybody all I'm thinking
so man they want like one blonde
conservative voice yeah to get mad at
it's it's a it's mantid everything too
you know they all get upset they always
have one blonde conservative on that
they can take all their anger on the
first time I did her she started to lose
weight after I did her cuz I think she
was offended uh and then she was on like
she got a trainer and she was like
starting to lose weight cuz she started
to slim down and then I started to slim
down so you could do more and I could do
her again and she's porking up down then
I port this it's like I very much mirror
her body and you follow so that's gotta
be good news when you notice that she's
gaining a little bit of weight yeah I
let it loose yeah good yeah
but she's you know she's a person who I
think should see the humor in it you
know ya know if she I mean this is
somebody who said her favorite
restaurant is PF Changs
made fun of right no they make you want
to not be made fun you bring up your dad
every 15 minutes right you know I mean
you say some wild stuff then you know
just it's fun we're just having fun well
you're a public figure and somebody's
doing an impression of you it's probably
not gonna be flattering so no one is
gonna like the impression yeah nobody's
gonna like I also think that this could
have been on MADtv in the 90s like I
just think it we've gone so in another
direction that you know all this stuff
is like you know it's online now this
way you'll find anything that has teeth
most of it is online yes and you know
just even I said now like everything's
soft touch you know nobody really rips
in anything everything's a soft touch
and like you gotta go online and get
anything
you